thank you so much for watching this
conversation is brought to you by our
friends at hbo max stream all your
favorites at hbomax.com
after all these years going back to
where it all started
back to the matrix
what superhero are you
peacemaker
there's no superhero called peacemaker
so one of the reasons i was really
excited to do this is because obviously
i'm combining two of my favorite things
sports and movies okay
so we have to start there with your top
five sports movies and they have to be
in order
oh that's tough in order yes cause you
know the cop out is just to say them all
you gotta rank this word i gotta rank
the sports movies okay i'm going with
number one
oh man uh white men can't jump
great
great start number two i'm gonna go with
any given sunday
three i'm going with sandlot
um
[Music]
for
i'm gonna go with
remember the titans and five and go to
hardball bias yeah i gotta pick harper
yeah there is a big one missing but it
is all opinion there was no he got game
oh man yes yeah see i'm gonna save you
there there's no he got games yes all
right i'll swap
i swap remember the titans and he got
gay okay yeah
all right are we missing any other big
ones
i mean are you like uh
are you like a major league are you a
jerry maguire are you any of
uh
they don't really rank i was gonna say
space jam one yeah what i'm saying just
as a straight classic uh but
i don't know field the dreams was i
guess like yeah that counts right yeah
that counts yeah such an unrealistic
plot mighty ducks a mighty duck
yes but your list is solid so i'll take
that and start there and yeah you passed
that test you started with a really good
one white men can jump you have to you
have to begin with that and you put he
got game in there so it it all worked
out okay but you were of course run
friday night lights you did a sports tv
show what do you like doing better tv
shows and movies
i think
that's a good question i think
it evolved over time i used to
enjoy doing
television because it gave
it gave the actor time to develop and
grow the character it gave time for the
audience to actually fall in love with a
character um
like i don't know how much like sympathy
and empathy you would have for like
wallace on the wire if it was only like
one episode you know rather than you
know an entire season to be able to kind
of like really like
make his death that much more tragic and
meaningful yeah
uh
and then i think there was a time where
i didn't know if i could
open a film or carry a movie you know
was i a leading man so like fruitville
kind of
answered a lot of those questions for me
at a young at a you know younger age
and i enjoy you know a beginning and an
end you know i kind of know where i'm
going so i can arc and character out i
could actually like be intentional with
my choices knowing where i'm gonna go in
tv you don't really know where the next
season's gonna take you you don't know
you know what's really going to happen
with your character so you're just
you're in the moment so i think it's
just a different muscle and a want and i
think now at this age
you know you're you're looking for
you know the best material
if it's a character that's really rich
and interesting
i might want more time i think that
movies leave you feeling satisfied
but there's something very intimate
about television shows because
you're almost inviting those people into
your home right like every single week
on wednesday or whatever the day is i'm
hanging out with these people and i feel
like i know them and there's just
there is more of a connection there but
i don't know if you always feel as full
um so there's something nice about
having this full character that that's
in a movie yeah you said something
interesting um talking about when you're
doing fruitful station you said that you
would ask yourself am i a leading man
when did you get that definitive answer
that you were a leading man and how long
did you struggle with that question
that's a good question uh
i think
i think that
on paper answered the question
uh with
you know the success that movie had
i think probably
creed
one for me
really kind of it kind of resonated a
bit more i think there's a lot of like
an imposter syndrome that followed
at during that time of figuring out you
know your place in the industry your
place and you know
the movie business where are you
transitioning from tv to film you know
at a time where there was a shift in
like what was acceptable you know
um and yeah you just you know
having faith in what you're doing but i
think after creed one it started to
really like
sit in and
and then like you might you know your
family and your close friends they they
you know having to remind you of
where you are i used to like try to
you know
i don't believe my own hype i don't i
don't you know drink my own kool-aid a
little bit i just you know
i like doing the work and you know
trying to be the best version of myself
so there's this um
this quote it's by this greek writer
named nicos
and he said
i once saw a bee drown in honey and i
understood
and that's kind of what i think about
when you hear when you say you know i
was just trying to make sure i stayed
level and there was all this like
goodness around me there's people
telling me about all this goodness
around me
but i don't want to be overpowered
by that but i'm sure that also though is
a struggle in itself too it's a balance
between like owning your blessings and
your success and the path that you've
been on and the things that you went
through to get what you have
you know
and
remembering where they came from i think
when you're living in your purpose and
you're blessed enough to
feel like what you're doing every day is
something that you're supposed to be
doing
you know that's a blessing and you got
to live in that you know um
and all the other things around it start
to make it complicated and
uh but i think the success and stuff
just magnifies who you really are yeah
you know um
yeah but this hollywood thing is a
monster you see you know people
you know it's undefeated yeah yeah it's
uh i think it's
it's easy to get caught up in things you
probably shouldn't be caught up in
um but one of the great things about you
and i mean this i have never heard
anyone say anything other than the fact
that you are the nicest human being i'll
take that yeah like everyone just talks
about your smile and how kind you are
and that you're just genuine um and i
think that that shows with things like
what you're working on now like the
investor qqq legacy classic which is
going to highlight hbcus um
when i think about that title though
obviously what sticks out to me is the
legacy part of it and i want to talk
about hbcus but i want to talk a little
bit about you two first i know you've
done a lot of hvcu talking already
but how often
do you think about legacy all the time
i think about legacy a lot you know when
you think about things you want to be a
part of
and not just a flash in the pan
something that's going to stand you know
withstand the test of time that's going
to be around longer than
you know then my physical body is you
know life short
so
you think about how you want to be
remembered
uh
who did i help who did i put on who did
i
you know
um
nudge in the right direction so they can
achieve their dreams you know there's
that is
like things that those are things that i
think about
um
you know a lot and so
you know with uh
you know with invesco qq and the legacy
classic
it was an opportunity for me to really
try to pay it forward and open up the
platform and the space for these you
know hbcus that's been overlooked for
such a long time and especially in the
sports you know um
you know you know field losing you know
top prospects you know year after year
to like these bigger d1 schools that you
know obviously you know the goal you
know for a lot of these athletes is you
know get to the league so to be able to
make hbcus or help put them in a
position to be destination points i
think
uh was part of the the way of thinking
when it came to putting together this
one yeah
i actually remember seeing an interview
where you said your greatest fear
was being forgotten
is that so true yes
okay elaborate it came from a
personal place i guess the like
it was a
one of my partner's birthday who passed
away when i was younger and it was the
day after his birthday and i had forgot
that it was his birthday
and that feeling i was like oh man okay
yeah life's crazy right now ripping and
running all over the place
and it was a moment of like wow if i
i had a moment where i actually i forgot
that was his birthday and first time
that's ever happened
that feeling of
that realization of you know mortality
and people move on and life goes on you
know and people
[Music]
might forget about you in moments of
time doesn't mean that you're not
important doesn't mean that the love or
that bond or that relationship wasn't
there it just
there's the reality of that
so so that fear is something that i
think in moments
pushes you to you know
to make your life worth it you know to
make every moment count
uh to leave something behind
that you could be proud of that other
people could look to and being you know
inspired by
um
yeah i think i think that those those
are yeah so that yeah it's good yeah
yeah i forget yeah yeah good one uh
claire underwood great television
character i played by robin wright penn
in an episode she said
i don't want to be famous i want to be
significant
and i was like there actually is like
this small difference to that and i
think that what you're describing is
significance
um
that you want like you being here to
mean something like much bigger than the
fact that i was a famous movie star yeah
but like there was this this change to
that right and and there's something
that is going to last forever um and
leave a bigger impact and i think that
does start with things like this legacy
classic uh with invesco qq so i love
that uh hbcu specifically you touched on
why they are important do you feel a
cultural shift happening what https
definitely yeah you know i think it's
the right climate
um
you know all the
the stars are just you know aligning
in the right way where it's having a
real moment
and you can't let it pass you by you
know you have to like harness this
energy and momentum yeah and keep it and
keep it moving in the right direction
and i feel like knowing where you
came from knowing what's available to
you what's in support of you
um i think we naturally started to
gravitate towards that
and
you know the importance of the next
generation of how
they're taught what they understand what
they know about themselves that sense of
pride
is going to be very very crucial and
important to our future leaders you know
and to see
these young people out here
so strong outspoken
you know in the thick of it
it was uh very inspiring and and uh it
allowed me to i don't know
it was a moment in time you know you
hear stories of like you know your
grandmother your mom and all these other
things having their moment you know what
i'm saying yeah and it seems oh the old
stories yeah i love them yeah no and and
when it comes around and just look at
you right in the face like oh this is
our time yeah okay i get that you know
and and that's a that's a real life you
know moment so yeah it was cool
so i want to read this
quote and the stats that i thought about
hbcus because
yes they are so important to us but
hbcus really are vital to america so
black colleges account for just three
percent of the four-year nonprofit
colleges their alumni though account for
roughly 80 of black judges
50 of black lawyers and doctors their
students account for 25 of black
undergrads who earn degrees in stem so
that's important for myriad reasons but
you need black doctors right because you
need people that understand
us right
and the more that you have black people
in these
positions the more you can close certain
disparities so hbcus really are like a
motor that is keeping us running in a
lot of spaces and that is so important
but i do think the most important thing
about hbcus existing is that you're
never the only black person
you are always around people that just
like innately understand you right they
get the same jokes right they feel the
same way when we are scrolling on our
phones and seeing black people dying
every day and it's important to have
that that sense of community because so
i went to a pwi that's a predominantly
white institution if somebody if nobody
knows loved my school had a great time
but
there were so many times i was the only
black person in a classroom
and that has continued more in my life
being the only black person in many
rooms
and i'm sure it has happened to you too
is there a time that you really remember
like wow i am the only black person in
this room
hmm i mean i think
i think the the sad part of the answer
is that you know it's been that way for
such a long time you can't remember the
first 100 you know but there it's a
like i think we
we naturally
have become chameleons you know to adapt
to our environment to
you know from code switching to whatever
right like that's those are the tools
that at a young age you learn to kind of
navigate
at a certain
at a certain point i think i've always
had the
mindset you know through my parents you
know um of just being aware
and
never letting that
influence me to feel like a victim or
whatever it may be but just a sense of
empowerment to use that perception to my
advantage yes so it's always been a
calculating thing for me to
take those environments and
use them to my advantage to you know
whether it's trojan horse
situations you know i'm saying that's
you know where you just you know quietly
move in and next you know it's you know
we all in here totally and i mean there
has to be
the first like right there has to be the
person that
that gets us there and can create more
space for more people i know 2020 of
course was a watershed moment for
everyone
you were super active in all the
protesting
tell me
three ways 2020 changed you
three ways 2020
changed me um
i think it and this is you know
probably a cliche one i think it it it
made me
realize the importance of
time and family
being able to really spend time
you know my uncle i'm uncle now or
whatever so
uncle mike i go
uh myself you say there's nothing like
that like nice nephew love like it's
just different it's different yeah and
i've never had to i never experienced
that before so
you know being able to love that change
diapers and be around and be present
yeah i'm good i've actually got
great experiences with changing diapers
like my sister's actually a little
pissed that
you know i've gotten like the light
diapers all the time yeah literally i've
missed every blowout no they're not a
lot of people in the diaper yeah
i'm like oh you care about me my guy
what's up man yeah they're cool he's
like i'm not gonna do this it's not
gonna make sense i'll hold it for
tomorrow
mom gave me corn yesterday relax
chill
oh my gosh have you gotten thrown up on
yes okay i've got yeah i got to throw up
and i'm cool with that yeah yeah yeah i
deserved that one that was me that was
me um but no he he's awesome and just i
never knew i could love something so
much that i never had a chance to meet
like literally before i even met him it
was like oh my god i can't wait oh i
love it and uh so i think family okay um
spending time i think that was that was
something i definitely
learned from 2020. um
i've always been an introvert and kind
of being good with being by myself so i
think you're just reinforcing
just sitting still
and
getting back to like you know meditating
and and
and just resetting because
last few years before that it's been a
non-stop thing um
and you know and i was telling myself
that yeah after this next project i'm
gonna take a break for a couple years
and i'm gonna just actually just work on
i'm gonna live i'm gonna try have you
ever taken a break
no i didn't think so no no no it's a
thing that you tell yourself to feel
better yes you know
i wanted to live life you know i instead
of just watching it you know i mean it
was it was uh
and i also wanted to experience more
things so i could
have more
more things to pull from in my work
okay that's interesting you know you
know there's levels to it you know
there's
to be able to you know you got to see
more so you can you know you could talk
about more and have organic places that
of just experience you know um
so that was something that you know
obviously with everything else that
couldn't happen as much but yeah it uh
and then yeah so i wanted to take a
break but then i think during quarantine
my mind and appetite changed
and it
actually made me
more hungry and focused and driven so
coming out of when things started to
open back up
it
i had an energy and just like that
i haven't had before so
um
yeah i think way more determined i know
you care so much about your family i
know you care so much about your legacy
um
people that have money right at some
point
things shift from
i want to be rich
to i want my family to be rich to
i want my family that isn't even alive
yet to be rich
how much of a focus is generational
wealth for you
you've been doing your homeworks yes
this is easier i always i'm always ready
these are thought out no these are good
um i think about it a lot yeah yeah i
think about a lot i think um
you know
breaking that vicious cycle
of having to start over and over and
over knowing you know the family story
is a family history of
you know what the holidays meant to a
family of like what debt
you know trying to
meet this
you know
making sure
you know kids aren't left out and this
and that and you know doing what we can
and how that
just compiles you know you know debt and
that's just one area you know what i'm
saying of like the system that kind of
you know keeps us you know oppressed in
a lot of ways especially financially
yeah um
so and in some ways by design
in almost always by by design yeah you
know um and the education around that
and lack thereof
so
i know me i'm learning things for the
first time that a lot of my family
hasn't had the opportunity
to be exposed to
so
that pressure of knowing that
and not caring about it i think is
irresponsible
so
you know yeah there's a motivation of
yeah i want these nice things or yeah i
want to be comfortable but also comes in
it's like yo i can't even enjoy this
comfort if my family's not straight like
what do i look like living here feeling
like this having these things it would
mean nothing yeah they don't have that
and are able to share these experiences
with me and then it trickles down to the
bigger picture of like you know when i
do have kids when i do have you know
grandchildren and this and that and
you know how do i make sure that they
don't have to burden the things that
i've had to experience growing up and
starting over and having you know just
all those things obviously money is to
buy things at its base
but what does having money like signify
for you does that make sense like what
does
that mean to your life to your family's
life to be able to have it
uh giving us options
yeah freedom freedom yeah i think you
know money signifies you know
in the the basic sense of just options
and access and opportunity
you mentioned growing up tell me uh
obviously the investor qq classic is in
newark yep tell me about your newark
my newark my brick city uh yeah now
that's why it was really important to
have you know the legacy classic there
you know at prudential center places
that i've been to growing up wanting to
be an example you know for the community
and the kids there that okay cool there
that we're bringing it back to
you know our roots so to speak
i mean my newark is you know
it was fun you know from
you know hooping in the park you know i
mean to you know taking the path over to
the city for auditions to
you know taking the bus home from school
and
you know
high school parties you know i'm saying
hit squad parties and street teams you
know okay
just the whole you know what what that
meant was was was everything you know
yeah a lot of great people from new york
too whitney houston from new york i
believe shaq was born in new york shag's
morning north too yeah it's queen
latifah from newark clinton from norway
okay yeah so yeah
y'all producing them i'm not i'm not
saying it's like gwynette county
you know what i mean
don't play me bruno county's in georgia
okay everybody everybody coming from out
there okay cool that song is about at
the north you notice a little some
summon is what it is but uh newark is a
great spot i've i've been there a bunch
um
but i think that people kind of have an
idea of what places are but it's just
like this blip on the map they don't
really know
what a place is like like when i think
about there's a balsa player jalen green
he was just drafted he's from fresno
california
people like hear california like oh this
is probably some cute little town he's
like no fresno yeah fresno we're not
playing with you like fresno is a thing
and there are parts of newark that are
the exact same way one thousand percent
yeah and i don't really know if people
they're just like new jersey it's near
new york whatever yeah i mean it's like
newark is
you know we got a little chip on our
shoulder i think totally i think growing
up
i think being next to a city like
manhattan new york
gives you like the little brother
complex a little bit it's like yeah you
know what you're talking about like no
we're just as good we ain't got no sales
tax on clothes y'all be coming over here
shopping all the time like it's like
we're very proud of the things that we
that that we have um and is known for
but it makes us scrappy and it makes us
like determined totally i think going
you know
you know you know west new york or we
hawking and looking over at the skyline
and seeing the city seeing those big
buildings and what that represents of
like oh i got to get there one day i got
i got a you know i want a piece of that
you know i think it gives you a
motivation um
and a drive a bit but
newark is you know
it's tough
you know it's it's uh
you know it was it was it was hard for
sure but you know it's
it's got a lot of promise and a lot of
talent you know and a lot of opportunity
um there as well
uh you know just
just
the timing you know i think i think it
it you know needs people to reinvest you
know back in you know pour back into the
city um
and i think
there's places like the fresnos and you
know and the newarks and you know all
these little places that are you know
throughout the country that you know
produce talent and people that you know
kind of
somehow
make it out of the circumstances in
their environments in a big way
that you know turn back around and be
like all right how do i
help reinvest and help
nurture the place that i came from you
know so so it's a process i have to say
i hear you talking about you know
reinvesting pouring back in i think
about this class of giving back to the
community and you know this deep love of
of black people i can't help but think
about killmonger
and
after black panther came out i swear i
had this debate for like three months
obviously there's no definitive answer
opinion is opinion but
is killmonger a villain
no
please tell me why i agree i think like
he's an antagonist
yeah exactly but i don't know if he's
like a bad person
what is your take on it
my take on and i'm also so right i'm so
happy that i can say we agree on this
no one agreed with me okay yeah please
continue you know that feeling when
you're like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah how are you going to
argue with killmonger okay
all right that's a good one that's a
good one give me your job
no i think i think he was a a necessary
part of the conversation yes you know i
think i think
you know he cared about his people just
as much as you know t'challa
um
he just had a different
way of going about getting it done yeah
um i think he was a historian that
studied
history you know the history of
you know
government and
oppression and
you know eric's a really smart guy you
know i'm saying mit graduate the guy is
like he's very intelligent and he
he um he saw that there was only really
one way to change things you know uh so
he went about that and i don't think his
argument was
completely wrong i don't think
t'challa's argument was completely wrong
i think it was a necessary conversation
that needed to be had it needed to to be
had
um
but you know it's a movie also so you
gotta you know
and that conversation makes it good
right i'm willing i'm willing to take
life you know what i'm saying to do
whatever it takes you know and this is
what i've been taught
this is what i've been shown that works
you know so you can not like it but
there's this other version
of trying to get change done and it's
kind of taking a little too long for me
i ain't got that time you know and i and
i yeah i guess but
i'm doing it like this yeah i love it
and and i i totally agree it's like
wanting the same thing with different
methods i mean maybe a little difference
in in the thing but the result is pretty
similar right just the empowerment of
that people they both wanted that it's
like you know like i said people always
kind of do the whole martin and malcolm
approach yeah they wanted the same thing
they just had they just kind of had some
different ways going about it but i'm
just right now i'm just happy i can't
even really focus on what you said yeah
you got that one yeah this is the one
for me and that's truly all i care about
um
so i know obviously you love sports we
gotta talk about some sports yeah i have
something for you
i had a friend of mine okay in the
midwest
okay has a little something that um
they want to say to you so we're gonna
we're gonna play that for you well
michael b jordan oh my man okay
so much for being a college basketball
fan
for being a michigan state fan we got to
get you some gear so the next time
you're on tv
supporting the greenhouse
magic together or something but i also
wanted to tell you that we'd like to
invite you back
to midnight madness or to one of those
big games in our arena place will go
crazy
so once again michael thank you for
everything you've done you got to
congratulations part of the success
you've had
keep your hand in college basketball
there it is that's awesome that's great
he's the best the shout out tim shout
out to mike shout out to max everybody
there that's that yeah i got you i'll
make sure i send that to you so you have
you have it so that's what happens when
you do your podcast
hello something you know shout out to
bobby because me and bobby were talking
i was like you know he likes michigan
street we were debating the giants i was
like i'm pretty sure he's a giant
i was like but i think he's more of a
michigan stadium
so
shout out to bobby who's in here
somewhere acting like he don't hear me
but uh yeah so i'll tell him that you
saw that why michigan state
growing up as a kid is always watching
it on tv like it wasn't really like a
rhyme or reason then you know realizing
you know magic johnson came out of there
you know and then just watching those
ncaa games with like with team cleves
playing for them and then you know
ultimately watching draymond play
through there so it was just for me you
know
i just always
you know dug the organization
yeah there wasn't really like it's not
no
real deep it's just
well you got lucky because it's a good
pick like that's a good school
to just kind of fall into into being a
fan of yep you at this point you are
kind of like a figure in sports culture
too you know like you sit courtside at
the games
and i want to ask you about the process
of sitting courtside because to you it
probably feels very normal
but the majority of humans have never
done that they've never sat courtside
they number one don't know that once you
sit coarsely you can't go back
it's like
it's like it's kind of like first class
a little bit i was justified
yeah it's like i'll catch y'all later
because i ain't going back cookies yeah
yeah free drinks get the blinking in the
pillow and delta one you ain't walking
past
no more it's tough yeah so why is it why
is sitting courtside just like unlike
anything like tell someone who's never
been
what it is like
i'm coming from a hooper's perspective
so it's like
playing in like tournaments and games
and like you know
competing you know in organized sports
when
when you're sitting courtside it's
almost like
being back at the gym mm-hmm you know
what i'm saying you're hearing the
sneakers you're hearing the talking yeah
you know i'm saying you're hearing
you're paying attention to the game
within the game yes and i think the
better part that's the part listen if i
don't even know if endorsements would be
able to handle like paying for audio
like if i could pay for like audio of
cats like everybody else
everybody loses their brain
deals out of here everything's done
actually but
that part of the game to experience is
you can't
it's really hard to explain to somebody
who hasn't been there but that's i think
the the specialness of sitting courtside
and being the best thing you've heard
courtside
oh i can't say that oh it's like yeah
grand it's like no no i mean it's like
out of respect for like what's being
said it's like really tough i think like
uh
which i think was
you know just
having moments where like you know
like say like lebron or whatever and
he'll come down
not that he tells you exactly what he's
gonna do but he insinuates he's about to
do it and then actually like doing it
and then kind of giving you a night of
like i told you so it's like one of
those tell me one of those moments like
that we all saw that you're like he said
he was about to do this and he went and
did it it was more on the defensive end
it was uh i can't remember the team that
he was playing but it was
it was
some somebody kept
i think getting behind
getting behind the defense or whatever
and it was easy layups i'm saying
somebody wasn't getting back or
something like that
and i remember him making an adjustment
and actually being last man back the
last time i want to say it was outlet
fast break something like that and he
ended up like you know breaking up a
pass or whatever the case may be and
then you know i'm saying he got amped up
everybody came over tapped him up or
whatever and it was a little like yeah
like i made the adjustment like his iq
and um
his court awareness you know what i'm
saying and his basketball iq was so high
like just knowing what needs to be done
and the adjustments to be made i think
was really really uh was really cool to
see up close and personal so that's just
a i can't remember exact moment but
that's something that i do remember you
know no i know totally what you mean it
was doing or whatever that was the best
part for me about being in the bubble
because you're essentially like
courtside every game and there's no
people in there so when i say you hear
like the smallest little thing oh yeah
it was just great i had a
i don't want to say like a new respect
for the game because i really respect
the game but i had just like a new
understanding
of what it's really like
out there for nba players when they're
going at it so
i love i was like i'm never going back
either i mean me getting the ticket a
little different than you getting a
ticket but i i mean i'll be down there
though
um i know and i do got no i do have
another moment about code yeah i'd love
to hear about that it was uh courtside
sitting next to him i can't remember
what game it was
but uh
but my experience is kind of the
opposite he's so locked in he doesn't
break
so like being the same like saying
what's up to him in like warm-up lines
all that good stuff was cool
but then when the game was on
sitting like right you know two seats
away from him you know i mean it's just
kind of like how focused he is
on
what he's in the middle of and what he's
doing mm-hmm
even when you try to get you know what
i'm saying like you know hey i'm still
sitting here i mean i'm saying same guy
i said what's up too like yeah we know
each other we actually work together
yeah talk to me you're telling me
nothing okay cool it's like you respect
the workplace you know what i'm saying
in the drive of like of what mission
he's out on right now so that was just
like a you know the opposite of how
at the opposite but just he just was so
locked in mm-hmm it was it was a
you know always impressive yeah he was
inspired he was different when i think
about you know being courtside
seeing kobe and gigi courtside together
and you just know he is pouring this
knowledge into her about this game that
you're literally not going to get
anywhere else exactly it was just like
such a such a special moment so
obviously rest in peace to kobe thinking
about gigi and his family and all that
stuff so that's really great that you
were able to have this courtside
experience with him then yeah it was it
was special yeah yeah and you've had
some really cool courtside experiences i
know the viral moment of you and drake
courtside what's it like being at a game
with drake
uh
so i feel like he'd be talking he'd be
talking no we we i mean we we talk [ __ ]
so it was like it's it's you know you
going in the game with one of your
partners it's like you you know yeah
yeah you it's what you'll be saying at
home but you're there so you actually
could talk to him yeah i mean and so
that was that was always that was a good
time yeah like courtside is is fun when
you're with you know people who know how
to enjoy it yeah
it was a good time amazing last little
uh part for you i'm very fascinated
by obviously actors playing these roles
these roles that probably at times just
feel like huge to play and you probably
take parts of
these characters with you in some ways
so i just want to name some of your
characters can you tell me what you've
taken
from that character that i name
uh let's start with killmonger oof
uh
yeah that was one that
um stuck i mean yeah still there it's uh
i think
the unapologetic nature
of
doing what he felt was right
i think there was a
a freeing experience to play eric that
allowed me to dive into parts of my
personality that i normally
would downplay
or not really can you tell me a part
uh
i think it's the unapologetic nature of
it i think there was a certain level of
not giving a [ __ ]
that he had
um that
i kind of had to tap into
okay i like that i remember seeing that
you for a bit went to therapy after you
were done playing come on or do you
continue to go i do okay good i'm a big
proponent of therapy i think everyone
should at least try it once yeah i think
so you know i think culturally and
generationally that it's something
that's been lost within our community a
little bit or not really like you know
grazed over and um i i do think it's
helpful
um
just to unpack a little bit yeah uh so
just to literally talk
yeah like that at its base is just
talking which i think everyone everyone
should do so i'm i'm glad that
one of the things that role led you to
do was try that so so that's really
important for sure okay wallace
wallace uh
that's wow because that it's kind of
it's got to be like a hindsight
perspective from that because i was so
young
that i
i wasn't really you know
up until like maybe mid middle of the
season
you know it
i tapped into more
where i really kind of like lost myself
in a role instead of like feeling like i
was acting
you know i think there's a little bit
like yeah that's interesting you know so
so in hindsight to be able to look at
the character
and be like what i probably took with me
from that is i guess the
vulnerability
you know i think he was pretty
vulnerable he was uh and he didn't want
to be in the circumstance yeah you know
i think he he he i think he felt the
most
out of
a lot of the characters that i've played
he's probably the most you know
raw and emotional totally okay i'm gonna
answer two more for you
oscar grant
oscar man
yeah oscar
ooh that i mean that kind of
you know as a whole
kicked off a whole
situ like movement
i felt like um
it's more like a
because of the real person you know it
wasn't like a you know some fictional
character you know being able to
to spend time with his family you know
and really get to know him and
understand who he was and you know
meditating on him and asking you know
his spirit to kind of be present with me
during that journey you know it's a it's
a tie
that's that's
you know
that
in the performance you know you want to
you have to
play that day out like there's going to
be a tomorrow
and there's a certain wow i never
thought about like that yeah i'm saying
it's a certain
like don't know how the story ends yeah
so i think
what he had to go through in those
moments is just the the frustration of
being treated like this and the constant
misunderstandings or the
you know
desire to just get home
i just want to go home like i just want
to get
here so i think that those frustrations
kind of like um
you know
something that
i think was
it took with me but it's something that
in hindsight again
yeah
you know one thing about you that a lot
of people don't do i've done a lot of
interviews you
think about
like you're very intentional with
whatever your answer is like you really
think about what your answer is before
you say your answer
which is something you should always do
because
trust me i'm not saying don't do it
you've done a great job okay because he
thinks about it exactly so i appreciate
the thoughtfulness of all your answers
but before i let you go i want to ask
is there anything that you want to talk
about or anything in your head that you
have not had the chance to discuss a
question you have not
been asked
and i don't mean today i mean yeah yeah
yeah
uh
you know
the past like year or so
um
i've been intentionally avoiding a lot
of
interviews and
uh you know
opportunities to speak on
certain stuff because
i felt like
i didn't have anything to say that
felt significant
in the sense of like
not
let me rephrase that i
didn't feel like talking about anything
that was insignificant
i was like there's too much going on
right now to be talking about these
other things that
in my mind right now
don't matter as much
so
you know
and then having to i guess
you know working on
directing you know and getting this next
project and that's kind of been that's
kind of consumed my my life you know uh
lately
um i've kind of you know just
you see so many things that's going on
and is wrong or you know not wrong but
just things that need to be addressed in
a real way like the right type of
questions and
though
that wasn't
interesting enough to places to want to
talk about you know or
you know it wasn't presented in the
right way you gotta you gotta
you
you can't be emotional
um
you just gotta be responsible with
your emotions and how you feel like
knowing where where we stand where we
sit
the
the voice that we have
it's
sometimes it's better just not to say
anything and just go and just be in your
world for a while until you're ready to
address
the system you know what we're doing you
know like this is a you know this is
what we do like
you know we we um
we're we're the messenger a lot of times
you know i'm saying yeah we have a
responsibility so i just felt like you
know
i could be more productive
getting some work done and then when
it's time for me to talk about and
readdress those things and things that i
felt like were important we could do
that then so okay well i'm being vague
enough you're being very yeah
but i'm still but i'm still you know
letting you know that you know that
there to answer your question plainly
there hasn't been a question that i
wanted to really answer
okay
no i'm with you yeah i see it well i
will close i know i i read a lot i have
a bunch of random quotes but what that
makes me think of is
you know the quote until the lion has a
historian history will always be told
from the point of view of the hunter
i think something that's really special
about what i'm able to do too but really
what you're able to do storytelling is
you get to be
a lion and a historian
and i think that's so great and you have
really been i just think a
representation
for people to see the things that are
possible but also the stories that are
possible and diversifying the things
that we see because for so long
roles of black people black men
were one thing
and as people like you that really
opened that space up for everybody not
just to like be in those rooms but to
see it
um so and i know that you know that but
just you know continuing to do you know
all the all the things that you do is is
so incredibly important and i loved this
and i hope that you were able to get you
know things out of it as well because
interviews should be they should be
mutual you should feel you should feel
hurt as well anytime appreciate all that
and we definitely do yeah absolutely
well hey i'm ready for the classic okay
that's what i know we're gonna be in
newark that's right prudential center
yes and basketball qqq legacy classic
yeah so people who want to watch the
classic in person not on tnt how do they
do it uh december 18th go to
proofcenter.com
legacy dash classic and then you could
buy tickets there and uh
yeah it's pretty straightforward and
simple yeah prudential center in newark
new jersey
uh the invesco qqq legacy classic there
we go we in there in the building